[Music]  hello everyone  thanks for all your support now that  I've had a bit of time to breathe since  the World Championship I want to create  something to share to the chess  community in this app you can spend some  time getting to know me let me teach you  and challenge me to a game or to the  part I'm most excited about is that I'll  be playing against winners from the app  annually live a secret location all you  have to do is download the app sign up  and then play chess to earn points and I  very much hope that you'll enjoy what  the app holds but I won't stop here as  we continue to develop you will get  updated training material personal  updates for me as well as future gaming  functionality such as multiplayer and  live online I might even pop online for  a game  [Music]  you